this presentation is delivered by the
Stanford center for professional
development
to welcome you to the dfj entrepreneur
thought leader lecture series and we
always have a room full of students but
also guess so one of the groups I want
to acknowledge days we have a group of
faculty here from Chile so if you're a
faculty member from Chile when you raise
your hand so everyone can see you okay
welcome hola okay great are there any
other groups of here that we should
acknowledge anyone raise your hand if
you're a visitor okay great so welcome
and we're delighted to have you here
this is open every week and we love to
make this available to our students here
but it's also available online if you
can't be here in person you can always
go to the website ecor nerd stanford.edu
and watch the videos video clips podcast
you can get the e corner app for your
iPhone so you can download it and
basically have these lectures anywhere
anywhere in the world this has brought
to every week by the Stanford Technology
Ventures program and also by basis the
business association of Stanford aunt
Pearl's students you can watch it online
as I said at a corner but also it's
brought to us by the Stanford center for
professional development it is my
incredible honor to introduce our guest
today Jeff yang is a founding partner at
redpoint ventures and his focus is on
consumer media and infrastructure the
thing that must be relevant to you is
that he was also an engineering student
you got an engineering degree from
Princeton and then got his MBA at
Stanford Business School I'm sure he's
got a lot to share with us Jeff thank
you
thanks Tina it's a pleasure to be here
with you all my contact information is
here as is my twitter handle and if you
fall if you don't follow me feel free if
you'd like to if you do I apologize for
all the spam that came out today
apparently somebody hacked my my Twitter
account and was throwing out all this
advice on how to lose 20 pounds in two
weeks and I I actually didn't realize
how many friends I had because I had a
whole mailbox full of direct messages
earlier on Twitter and you know people
said people are asking all about you
know all these nutrients and things and
and next thing you know it's it i guess
it's nice to hear from your friends but
i wish it hadn't been about losing 20
pounds in two weeks but if you're
interested I'll pass those on you what I
wanted to talk to you about for the next
40 minutes or so is a little bit about
about timing generally right and I think
it's a very popular topic right now
about all the opportunities that are out
in the market and and as you know
entrepreneurial activity is about as
fervent as it's ever been and I'm sure
some of you are thinking wow maybe
someday or maybe now I'm going to start
a company and what I want to talk to you
a little bit about is is you know if you
if you're ever thinking about it you
know sometime now in the future I want
to talk to you a little bit about the
founders and kind of what makes in my
opinion some of the attributes as
successful founders i'll talk about
markets because you know there's always
this this age-old debate what's more
important you know the the the
management or the market right it's a
little bit like the chicken or the egg
and and it's at the end of the day every
argument in history will come down to
what's more important is that the people
or is it the market and and you can make
your own decision i happen to be at the
margin kind of a markets person but i'll
tell you a little bit more about that
and attributes of an attractive market
i'll talk a little bit about growing a
company and financing a company in case
you're thinking of starting something
want to get it financed and this is a
lot of this is generic i mean obviously
I'm a venture capital so I'm going to
give you my perspective but I'm trying
to keep it somewhat balanced because
venture capital isn't for everybody and
we'll talk about that for a minute and
then and then I'll give you some
a little bit of insight on how we
evaluate opportunities and and even if
you don't go end up going to a venture
capitalist I always think it's great to
have the lens of of you as a prospective
investor because as an entrepreneur you
know many of you will be investing your
time which is arguably an even more
valuable resource than than money so
with that I'd I'll just I'll just start
with just you know founders are just
extraordinary and entrepreneurs are
extraordinary and there aren't really
any ordinary ones I mean I've got some
pictures of some of the people we've
backed recently you know Dave Morin
who's a CEO path before he started path
he was a kind of co-creator of facebook
connect and the facebook platform before
that he had been at Apple where he had
gone right out of school you know from
Boulder then you then you have you have
kevin here from stripe he was at age 16
won the European Science Award and then
end up going to MIT started a company
that was trying to build tools for for
making a Bay a more efficient
environment ended up selling that pretty
much within a year after starting it you
know they always talk about how he
became kind of a millionaire kind of
overnight at age 18 or 19 and then ended
up when he sold the company stayed there
for a couple years and dropped out of
MIT and then it is starting stripe in
2010 which is a way to a econ payment
and able kind of any website and they're
going through pretty some pretty
substantial growth you've katarina fake
next to next to him and she finished
Vassar and went to join the well which
is one of the first online communities
in 1985 went and started flicker flicker
was then sold to Yahoo then she started
hunch hunch was then sold and and
recently we backed her starting
something called finder e which is
trying to bring life to locations you
know but if if walls could talk so you
could leave notes
all over the place and next to her is
fellow named Christian you're gay who is
running a company called tidemark right
now Christian has a really compelling
personal story he's a refugee from
Romania when he left there were armed
guard shooting at him as he's swimming
across the river ended up getting to New
York drove a cab ended up owning a limo
service he was a computer scientist in
Romania so then he ended up starting a
company called outlooks off which did
business analytics assaulted Hyperion
for about four and a million dollars and
now he's doing the same thing for
business analytics you know in the cloud
so I mean all these people have very
kind of compelling stories as
entrepreneurs and and at the end of the
day no entrepreneurs or no founders are
kind of ordinary you know there they all
have you know very interesting kind of
compelling stories so you know as I talk
a little bit about a founders and you
know they're they're a bunch of kind of
myths that I just wanted to talk a
little bit about you know the first is
founders first ideas second and the
notion is you know I'm going to decide
to start a company and once I just
started start a company I'll find an
idea and an ideal will just come to me
and that's how i'm going to start the
company and and you know my point of
view is that you know entrepreneurs
really aren't created they're compelled
and the best entrepreneurs are the ones
that have they come up with this idea
and they think this idea is going to
change the world and I if I don't do it
I don't know who else is going to do it
and and I think the world would be a
better place by starting it so I don't
believe that its founder first ideas
second I really think it's idea first
and the idea compels the founder and and
that you have to have a passion for it
you can't just decide well I'm going to
start a company because it's in my I'm
planning my career now is the right time
for me to start a company or I see a lot
of other people starting companies so I
should go start a company you have to be
passionate about it and it's got to
drive you and like compel you to start a
company the second common myth is well
it's either Now or Never now's the time
and everybody else is doing it I should
do it and
and you know whether or not I'm ready
you're never really ready I should go do
it you know III really believe that that
the best entrepreneurs and I'll tell you
some more stories about some of the
entrepreneurs as we go along or happy to
do so they build a foundation right and
they they learn and make mistakes on
someone else's nickel they figure out
you know for instance you learn how to
manage and engineering products you
learn how to spec projects you learn how
to manage people you learn how to do
cost-benefit analyses you learn how to
scope markets and what's a big market
what's a little market you learn to hire
and fire people right and and the
ability to do that on someone else's
nickel and somewhat in some ways you
know make mistake on someone else's
nickel it is really an incredible luxury
and it's also an opportunity to expand
your network you know the best way to to
start a company i think is to to to
bring people that you know are really
incredible people that you can rely on
then you can trust and you may not want
to take a lot of risk you know on those
people so the extent that you know them
and you've worked with them or you know
other people who know them is is really
important so you know it isn't always
now or never the third you know common
myth is that homework is for losers you
know I I the point of view would be well
you know you never know everything I'm
just going to go with my gut and I kind
of feel as if I'm ready and I'm just
going to go do this even though I
haven't really done any homework and and
I really disagree with that you know
certainly you can't know everything you
know when you're starting a new company
especially one where you're you're doing
something that no one ever has been able
to do before you know people will say
well how do i do market analysis on a
market that doesn't really exist well
you know in my opinion when you're going
and starting and you're putting your
energy in starting a company you're
really making pretty significant
investment just as if you know when I
when we invest in a company we're making
a very significant investment and you
owe it to yourself to do your homework
you owe it to yourself to go find out
what is the competition doing how big is
this market what are the reasons why it
might fail
or why it might might succeed and and
really kind of put together the whole
the whole landscape of what you're
counting on for this to be a successful
venture and if you don't do that you're
kind of cutting yourself short and and I
mention this because it's kind of
amazing to me when I meet entrepreneurs
and they really haven't done any
homework on how big the market sizes or
you ask them about well what is this
person you know what is this company
doing or what is that person doing over
you heard of this we heard of that and
they said no haven't really done any
that work you know it really is not the
right way to go about doing this because
you are making an investment and you're
making investment in the most valuable
thing you have which is your time your
energy and your reputation and you owe
it to yourself to do some homework that
isn't to say that you need to know
everything and all your information
needs to be perfect you just need to
kind of know what you're betting on in
order to do that and the last one is boy
you know nothing like this has been
tried before and you know my opinion is
that almost every business model has
been tried it may not have been tried in
exactly that that business and that
incarnation but every you if you can
squint and you can think about well what
happened you know so for instance on
Monday at our partners we were talking
about subscription commerce right and
one of the big things one of the big
things popular things today is is you
know these are subscription commerce
sites where you sign up for a monthly
subscription to some either product or
service or or what have you and it just
comes and people will say well is this
model working though well you never know
it hasn't really been tried before well
you know you go all the way back to the
early 70s and there was this thing
called Columbia House you know records
and tape where every memory every month
they'd send you three new albums and
unless you canceled you know it would
the album would come or you think about
Justin I analogy AOL you know it's a
monthly subscription service that if you
didn't cancel you know it would your
credit card would just be renewed and
and the fact that you know my belief is
that almost every model has been tried
and made haven't been exactly tried in
that industry it may be you know
different industry
ease within different periods of time
but they're very instructive as to you
know how corporations view it or how
consumers view it and and how behavior
kind of works and and you know I always
encourage entrepreneurs and I always ask
them what's the analogy for this
business you know what is it most like
is it like you know it's is it like how
Cisco did it or is it like a Federal
Express did it or is it like you know if
it's a rien even restaurant analogies
whatever I I always look for analogies
and i think i think it's it's really a
myth that nothing like this has ever
been tried before so if you if you take
a step from there and i just want to
share with you some attributes of what i
think great entrepreneurs do in my
experience you know and i talked about
this minute ago entrepreneurs have a
driving passion to change the world and
you know what I don't love lots of times
when when I will go and think about
investing in a company one of the things
I really like to do is understand why an
entrepreneur wants to start the company
what's driving them to succeed and
almost I can almost never get that in a
meeting it takes a few meetings to do
that and I usually go to dinner to go to
dinner with the entrepreneur and you
know if I could I would figure a way to
meet their family I'd figure way to play
a sport with them I figure a way to do
you know just whatever just to kind of
understand what their psyche is but I
almost always end up talking about well
why do you want to you know why do you
want to do this and and really what I'm
looking for is what's driving them and
if they say I want to make a lot of
money that that's not I don't think
that's enough to be a driving passion to
want to change the world you know it if
it works out and you're lucky enough to
that a company is really successful you
know that's that's terrific and it's
going to be financially really lucrative
but that's more the the effect and it's
really not the cause right the cause is
that they have a vision they want to
change the world and they want to make
the world you know a better place and I
always spend time trying to understand
what is the person's passion and
I what's going to cause them to you know
walk run through concrete walls in order
to make it happen because you know as
you'll see in a minute I'm going to talk
about willing a company to success you
know they're going to go and they're
going to convince other people to leave
their jobs and and take to take salary
cuts and really bet their careers and
before you know you're going to have
hundreds of people around the company
they're betting on this person and the
passion of what the original vision was
and it can't be just to make money that
is a that's a horrible culture that will
never survive it's got to be about you
know I'm going to change the world I
have this vision about how to make this
a better world the second big the second
attribute of winning entrepreneurs i
think is is the ability to see chaos see
patterns where others people see chaos I
talk a lot about this about pattern
recognition I get people coming in and
they'll say oh I see this trunk and it's
it's really interesting it's going to be
the best trunk in the world and someone
else comes in and says well it's going
to be a foot and I know how we're going
to make the best foot there is in the
world someone else comes in and says
well I got a I got a I got a tail it's
going to be the best tale I've ever seen
and someone else says you know I've got
a tusk and before you know it you know
you start seeing that everybody's kinda
scribing an elephant right and and part
of our job is venture capitalists is to
try to put all those pieces together and
try to recognize patterns the best
entrepreneurs that I see come in and say
well I see this happening over here I
see this happening over here I see this
happening over here the logical thing is
that now all the pieces are coming
together that that the world is going to
look like this and and you know they see
it as clear as day and and they feel
compelled to go get in front of that
market because they see if if they don't
do it they're not sure someone else will
or they can't stand the thought that
someone else is going to get there in
front of them the third is that you know
you have to have this passion you have
to have the conviction but you have to
be able to able to articulate it because
when you're starting a company all you
have is the power of the idea right and
if you can't convince other people
that it's the right idea so imagine that
that you're one person with this
fantastic idea and you're going to start
a social network and and it's just going
to be every you know the 900 million
people are going to are going to connect
but if you can't convince anybody else
to come help you how you ever going to
do it right and so you've got to be able
to have a vision and be able to
articulate it to other people so that
you can convince them to do it and that
they can convince other people to do it
and people put money into it and and
service providers will provide services
to it so being able to articulate it is
really an important point the fourth is
willing a company into existence you
know in the beginning there really as I
said there really isn't anything other
than an idea and the very the first five
hires and the first three or four months
you know all you have is your belief in
what you're doing is right and you have
to have the the conviction but you also
have to be able to have the fortitude to
be able to will but by force of will the
company you know exists and if you have
any doubt everybody else will see it in
you and and the company will never you
know us will never end up forming and so
you know my advice to you is to do all
your homework up front but once you
commit to do it if you commit to do it
you're going to do it and there is no
path back that doesn't mean to say that
you're going to be stupid and you're
going to be foolish but you got it will
companies to into existence the fifth is
you know I think entrepreneurs are
genetically paranoid anybody who's not
paranoid is going to end up getting
getting eaten hopefully not literally
the six is being able to recognize and
support your own weaknesses nobody's
perfect and the best entrepreneurs I see
you know understand what there is a
weaknesses are and they go hire other
people their team up with other people
or they they bring in as advisors or
board members people that can help them
be better and they recognize their own
weaknesses the seventh is soliciting
advice but you make your own decision so
I hear this all the time about well you
know as a board member they say well
what do you want to do and I and I said
well you know i'm going to give you
advice but you're going to be the one
who's going to make the decision and the
the best entrepreneurs I know they
solicit advice and they listen and they
process but they quickly make a decision
you don't want an entrepreneur that
won't listen solicit advice because you
know that's that then they say well you
know I know all the answers I'm not
going to ask for any help but you also
don't want one that says okay everybody
give me whatever you think and
collectively we're going to make this
this group decision that that and I'm
not going to make any decisions I want
somebody's going to listen but the end
of the day you know make their own
decision and be be responsible for that
decision and then lastly be able to make
decisions on incomplete information and
fix the bad ones along the way I end up
giving this advice probably nine to
ninety percent of the first time
entrepreneurs which is hey you can't get
all the information by the time you get
all the information it's too late and by
not making a decision you've made a
decision all I ask is you quickly make
decisions and if they're wrong fix the
bad ones quickly you know make just but
what you have to do is you have to rapid
fire decision making it because in an
early stage company you don't have the
luxury of time and if you did you'd end
up looking like a very large company
that has meetings about meetings and it
takes you know two or three years to
make a decision what young companies
have is the ability to kind of rally the
troops do something do it overnight make
the decision commit and move on and if
it's the wrong decision if you hire the
wrong person fire that person that's
okay as long as you do it quickly don't
don't linger on bad decisions and then
finally sweat the details I don't know
any really good entrepreneur that
doesn't sweat the details and this this
you know almost every great manager CEO
I know also you know knows knows the
important facts and can tell you that
got the clarity of saying what are the
what are the five or ten really
important variables that drive my
business and and once I know them I know
the details of those numbers right and I
always am very weary of a CEO comes in
who really doesn't know you know any of
the details of some of the most
important important variables
the important KPIs and and I'll talk a
little bit more about that in a second
so that's what I think make great
entrepreneurs the other aspect is you
know once you start a company you gotta
you gotta have some leadership right and
and not all entrepreneurs are great
leaders but some are and the ones that
are really good I think are the ones
that can clearly articulate a strategy
and a purpose you know as a company gets
bigger an entrepreneur can have less and
less direct control over the knobs they
have to be able to work through other
people and as you start developing a
larger organization you may have either
business units or you might have
functional units and you're going to be
less you're going to have your hands
less and less on the operation so what
you have to do is you have to create a
culture where everybody understands what
the big purposes of the the main
missions and the strategy of the company
and why what they're doing is important
to achieving that success so you have to
be able to clearly articulate a strategy
and a purpose I think they'll I think
great leaders lead by example you know
you can't say okay everybody we're going
to go really work really hard and I'm
going to go take a three-hour lunch and
and go take a swim by the pool
unfortunately it doesn't work that way
you know leadership happens by example
the third is that they recognize that
they win because the team wins lots of
times you'll see you know entrepreneurs
and leaders have many of them have very
big egos and the ones that succeed best
are the ones that recognize that for me
to succeed ever the team has to succeed
and you have to be able to to share
responsibility and share successes
because if you can't share
responsibility and share successes you
can't share failures and you can't pin a
bad outcomes on people right you have to
be able to understand that we got to win
and you win as a team and you have to
you have to be productive as a team the
fourth is that they never give up you
know you see this all the time in in
entrepreneurs offices you'll see the
signs that say never never ever ever
ever
ever give up right and that's you know
one of the things that I admire most
about entrepreneurs is that they'll
they'll come up to a stone wall and
they'll sit there and they'll try to
bang through the wall to try to bang
through the wall and you know some
people would walk away and they'll go
think about it overnight and next thing
you know they walk around the wall right
the you know the you you can it you
there's so many reasons why a startup
company should fail you know versus a
company that has a lot of resources a
lot of market share a lot of customers
and the reason they succeed is because
somebody has somebody has the nugget of
an idea and a passion to make it work
they have the people who are dedicated
and they adjust along the way right I've
never in my 27 years in the venture
business I've never seen a business plan
that was that we initially funded on on
the first round actually get executed
exactly the way that it was supposed to
be right almost everybody changes path
along the way and they do mid-course
Corrections and it's it's really
important and then the last is hiring up
almost great every great leader you'll
see will will always try to raise the
average with the next higher and and
I'll talk about that a second so I just
thought I'd just share with you a couple
of you know great entrepreneurs you know
the first is John McFarlane it's so
sonos and John was was that son he ended
up starting this company called software
com he sold it to phone calm and then he
started this company called sonos which
many of you may know is there they view
their mission statement as filling every
room in the house with music and and
they want to be able to play every song
in the world and stream it to every room
in the world and have people rediscover
the joy of music right and they do this
with you know set of wire wireless
speakers and and bridges and they
connect to music services but what John
does really really well is he's he's
incredibly committed to the vision and
he he would he was willing to do kind of
whatever it takes to fulfill a customer
value proposition which is he wants to
fill every house in in the world with
beautiful music and he wants everybody
to enjoy it and he's able to hire you
know some of the best people around the
world that that just you know and a lot
of us acoustic engineers and design
engineers are kind of different kind of
people but when you give him a chance to
say I want to give people the enjoyment
and rediscover music it's it's it's
really remarkable he's hired up a group
of people that all have worked with him
before and he's able to articulate a
grand vision and despite having been
extremely successful it all happens
because John is is at the helm and you
know he makes it work Ne and he leads by
example and I just I think the world of
them but but I also love his vision and
I'm completely bought into it another
another guy Reed Hastings that we backed
in netflix you originally came to us you
know his background was I was actually
in the Peace Corps and then he was in a
startup company that was a spin out of
any tea called adaptive and then he
started a company called pure software
which was ultimately sold for quite a
bit of money and then he came to us with
this idea that that he was going to he
was going to have mail order service for
DVD rentals and we said God isn't that
crazy why wouldn't people just go to
blockbuster and Rena Rena DVD and he
said well because you know this is much
easier and and consumers are really
getting ripped off now by all the late
fees and we really think we can you know
consumers would really like to have a
few DVDs around the house all the time
and we think we can have a logistic
system that can get that get than there
we think it'll be a significantly better
experience and we think it's better for
the consumer and if it's at the expense
of blockbusters it's going to be at the
expense of expensive blockbuster and you
know a lot of us thought it was kind of
crazy but every time we pushed on him on
well what about this why won't this
won't work because this model he had
thought about it and he showed us that
the nine reasons why we would work and
he
tell us all the people he talked to and
then we'd say well well you know this
won't work here because you know the
postal service going to take too long
and goes no I thought about this and and
and here here are the things to do about
this well and then the studios aren't
going to give you you know the dvds
didn't appropriate windows well yeah
we've talked to them and hero and this
was guy was so compelling that despite
the fact that we thought it was kind of
crazy we've just felt that this was kind
of a guy that wish we had to invest in
and and netflix has turned out to be a
pretty good company and even today you
know readers probably recognizes one of
the more entrepreneur you models of
entrepreneurial leadership and if you he
has he talks about something called
freedom and responsibilities that you
might want to just look up you know
there's a slide deck you can look up on
the internet that's pretty widely
distributed and when he talks about is
in a large organization he wants to give
everybody the freedom to do what they
think is the right thing to do for the
company and he wants to give them the
responsibility so that they feel as if
you know they have to own up to it both
for both the good results and the bad
results and Netflix is a remarkably
remarkably effective company where you
know everybody kind of knows what
they're trying to where they're trying
to go they all know what they're trying
what what what their role is and trying
to make that happen and you know he's
he's a remarkable leader and there's a
story that I just heard recently which I
thought was interesting would wear you
know he talks about this freedoms and
responsibilities thing and and one of
his employees said you know hey I think
everything your time on this freedom
responsibilities thing is BS and regos
why you as well you know if you really
believe that we should have the freedom
you're going to give us a responsibility
why do we have vacation days why do you
care why are you trying to legislate you
know what what how much time I take off
while all long as I get my work done and
read went back and he thought about he
said you're right so now they no longer
have vacation dates you basically take
take whatever time you need to take off
as long as you get your work done and
and it turns out that people take it
less vacation than they were otherwise
being titled but but you know that these
are examples of people who started the
companies from the get-go
but ever merged into terrific
entrepreneurial leaders so the next
section I want to talk a little bit
about is about markets and how you
should think about Marcus you know the
interesting thing is when I got in the
venture business market sizes were
measured in tens of millions or low
hundreds of millions of dollars and
they're mainly us the mainly data
processing oriented back offices today
their world worldwide and the measure of
tens of billions or hundreds of billions
of dollars and it's really kind of a
remarkable you know transition you know
for instance there 5.8 billion mobile
devices out in the world that's more
than people who have electricity or
clean water so you know it's kind of you
live in a really great time and and so
one of the things is trying to find the
right market at the right time and I
thought I'd just tell you you know a few
stories of companies that I'm involved
with so you know so I got involved with
tivo in the very beginning and it was it
was a couple a couple of guys who wanted
to build kind of a video server in the
home and the more we talked about it I
was just coming off the board of a
company called excite which was one of
the early internet search engines and
one of the things that we learned from
the internet was that targeting and
personalization the ability to target
and personalized content was really a
powerful notion and so I spent a lot of
time talking to them so well why can't
we do this for television why can't we
deliver a personalized television
experience so that people don't have to
just watch what's broadcast but they can
watch what they want to watch when they
want to watch it and then they came up
with you know how are we going to do it
and and lo and behold you know we had to
start with a set-top box but more
importantly we started with the user
experience and tebow was kind of born
and it was born at a time when I think
the internet started training people
that hey personalization is really
important and the television was kind of
ripe for for innovation I've got another
company I'm involved with called
machinima machinima is is a broadband
content network that sits on top of
YouTube and it's targeted mainly the
gamer so in July SR in August we served
2.3 billion videos to about almost 200
million people and it's it's kind of
growing like a weed and it's mainly gay
content and when I first met him it was
very it was really very small but it was
right around the time when a call of
duty modern warfare passed a billion
dollars the first video game to pass a
billion dollar revenue and then avatar
kind of in the same month passed a
billion dollars and I looked at the two
art forms I thought hey those are pretty
close I mean could it be that a lot of
this stuff and as you many of you know
who are gamers the the graphics are a
photorealistic and and it's kind of hard
to tell certain movies from from certain
games and in fact you go to movies today
and you see trailers you know for games
and I can't really tell in the beginning
if they're if they're promoting a movie
or they're promoting a game but you know
they started at a time and we invested
just you know on the Lark that said hey
maybe this might become important and
next thing you know YouTube is pouring
hundreds of million dollars to create
you know the largest broadband MSO MSO
in the world and you know our vision is
you know machinima machinima is to
gamers what ESPN is to sports right ESPN
isn't necessarily just about sports is
about males you know a 16 234 and that's
kind of what machine M is all about
bluefin is a spin out of MIT media labs
and some of the statistics on people who
watch television is about seventy
percent of all tablet users have their
tablet about sixty eight percent of
people who have a smartphone have their
second screen sitting in front of them
and people are tweeting away or they're
surfing or whatever so Bluefins idea was
hey could we take all this all these
information about what people are
posting on Twitter and on Facebook and
they're writing on blogs and could we
somehow correlate that to a full tv feed
and if we could if we could parse the
the TV stream into discrete events and
we could somehow associate social
response to what was happening you know
on television wouldn't that be kind of
cool and building the large world's
largest real-time focus group on the fly
right now what happens is you know a TV
show we'll come on and they'll do a
focus group testing about three weeks
later though they'll still do unaided
response rates and and they'll three
weeks later they'll be otay to people
like it what they like it would they not
like it well with bluefin and it's
really a large data analytics and
crunching problem they're able to tell
you almost real-time how people are
reacting so that you could change your
message and and there are examples of
during the Olympics of how people change
change their creative on on network
spots based on what reactions are of
people are in you know we think that's
kind of an interesting trend and it
wouldn't it really wouldn't be possible
without advances in computer technology
without algorithmic advances without all
everybody posting but it kind of all
came together at the right time and we
think it's a pretty interesting idea and
the last one is electric amp which is
founded by one of the Apple iPhone
engineers and and some of the Google
software engineers and the notion is
they want to create an Internet of
Things right and and their whole pitch
is now it's gotten to the point where
people really are wearable technology
home technology as I'm sure you've all
heard of nest which is you know the
thermostat you can control over the
Internet well what if you control
everything in your home over the
Internet wouldn't that be kind of cool
what what if there were lights and and
door locks and temperature stuff and
water and sprinklers and what if you
could put it on your dog to know where
your dog was and and what if you could
do it on your elderly grandmother just
to make sure she's safe or or what have
you wouldn't that be kind of a cool
thing and what they've developed as a
platform and a reference design to allow
anybody to kind of cook something onto
the internet for a very inexpensive
price and then a back-end cloud service
for connecting these things and monitor
these things either on a white label
basis or directly and and that that
isn't possible except for the fact that
you know Wi-Fi is pretty much everywhere
compute is is really inexpensive and you
know the ability to get miniaturization
I can get you know basically these
computers on the size of SD cards and I
can get them really inexpensively that's
kind of a cool thing and so you know the
point of this is that you know lots of
times you look for
you look for discrete patterns that
happen all come together at the same
time where you're able to say you know
what I'm talking about would not have
been possible or not have been
interesting until this point in time and
I think the ability to kind of look at a
really high level and decide wow that
must mean that there's an opportunity
here is is an important aspect of trying
to find the right market so one of the
questions I get asked a lot is well what
defines in tractive market well I think
the most attractive one is the ability
to do something that can't otherwise be
done right so without what I do then
there would be you know no market and
the ability to kind of create a market
is really interesting in and if you have
any doubt and you look at the market cap
of companies within any particular
sector you'll find that about fifty
percent of the market cap typically
accrues to the market share leader right
so it's very profitable to be the firt
not not only the first of the market but
if you're the first new to the market
share leader so the ability to kind of
help create a market is quite
interesting the second is you know
something that's fundamentally changes
the economics of a solution so by doing
it you can reduce the cost by x by x 10
x or sore or you you will you allow what
what typically wouldn't be able to have
be done you can now be done the third is
that it's in the path of progress you
don't need to know the market if the
market exists today and and it's being
adequately served you either have to
come in with something you know i always
talk about general rule of thumb of
attacking existing markets it's got to
be about 10x the performance and it
could be a maximum of three times the
price but but arguably in today's world
it's got a you know it's got to be
something along that that lines of a 30x
kind of improvement for people to switch
because otherwise you know corporations
or people would rather just stick with
you know what what they already what
they're already using so being able to
look at well if this happens here and
this happens here I
really think that this really is in the
path of progress and this is going to
happen so you know this notion of
something that is in the path of
progress and if it already exists it's
on the cover of Time magazine chances
are it's too late but if it's something
that is controversial but you can argue
is in the path of progress that's
probably a pretty good a pretty good
thing to take advantage of or take a
look at I should say and then the last
is what for me defines an attractive
market I want to be able to see how
company can get north of a hundred
million dollars of revenues you know if
it works and ideally multi hundreds of
millions of dollars of revenue now
that's from my perspective as a venture
capitalist that isn't true for for for
you know an individual investor or an
angel investor but you know for what I
do that's what I want so let's talk now
a little bit about investment and taking
the money and and I referred to this
earlier about whether or not to to vc or
not to vc right and the first is to say
venture capitalism for everybody right
there positives the positives are you
get professional help that's all what
all we do that's what we get paid to do
and hope are hopefully and arguably
we're okay at it and we have you know
you provide the help and the expertise
we have a very large network of contacts
both to hire to for partners for for
potential distribution arrangements you
know for all sorts of things we come in
with an unbiased set of eyes and brains
you know when you sign us up that
there's there's no there's no second
agenda it's not like you take money from
a corporation and a corporation as a
second agenda about you know the
investments only one thing you know our
our motivations are really clear we're
trying to make a great return for our
limited partners and we think the best
way to do that is by building a very
large long-lasting market share leading
company right we you know we're
extremely transparent and the final
thing is credibility lots of times you
know when a company gets venture finance
I'll do this all the time where I'll
call up a potential recruit and I'll
talk to them about all the other great
companies that we finance and why we
think this is the next one and we're
willing to put our reputation and our
dollar
behind it and that level of credibility
often you know right or wrong you know
is what's necessary to convince a
candidate to kind of leave a an
otherwise interesting job the negatives
are dilution you know we are very
ownership so very ownership oriented you
know our typical ownership in a
first-round investment is just just a
little under twenty-five percent right
we're very ownership hungry it's by no
means the cheapest money that you'll
find and you won't you'll give up a
little bit of control you know we don't
want to do is you know we don't want to
invest in something that's a hobby or
something that somebody that nobody ever
wants to get liquidity in and so by
signing on to you know for venture
capital your kind of your kind of buying
into that that that roadmap we have
certain outcome expectations you know as
I said you know something that is a at
least at our scale something that could
be a 10 or 15 or 20 million dollar you
know acquisition price may be very you
know maybe terrific as an angel
investment it just doesn't work for you
know an institutional venture capital
firm like ours because we're looking to
build you know very significant positive
holding positions and and and once you
go back once you start there's really no
going back you know once we come on in
and I'll talk about this some in right
here on the bottom point it really
becomes a marriage right you know we're
signing on we're signing on with you
you're signing on with us and we're
going to be in this journey for a long
period of time and and so when I talk to
potential companies that we invest in I
talked about going on the board I really
encourage them to do reference checks
and I really encourage them to take
their time because as much as we're
signing on with them they're signing on
with us and it's going to be probably a
56 year journey we're going to have
together it'll be a lot of fun and we'll
go through a lot of ups and downs and
it'll be thrilling and it's exciting but
it's really hard for us to get divorced
at the end of the day so in terms of
raising money you know I would say just
raise kind of generally what you need to
get to the next milestone proof pays in
other words once you get to the next
milestone it justifies an increase in
valuation and and that will minimize
your dilution and
and it's you know proof is is really
important to end and I see this all the
time because entrepreneurs will come in
and they'll say well I want to raise 15
million dollars and I say well you don't
really have that much what does it take
for you to get some initial market
feedback well that'll take a million and
a half or two million dollars well why
not why don't we do that you'll suffer
less dilution and it's probably a better
way to finance the company because I
can't write that big a check and take
that much risk but on a smaller check
you know I'd be willing to do that if
that kind of leads to the second thing
about stay lean and mean I don't know
why it is but companies do better when
they don't have that many resources
right you know they always talk about
necessity is the mother of invention
well it's definitely true and when
companies are really lean they end up
being more efficient and they figure out
ways to do it when you're there's a
there's a big slug of cash in the bank
people get a little bit lazier and if
you have a couple people that aren't
really contributing well we can afford
and we'll just leave them on the payroll
that's not the right thing to do the
right thing to do is if someone isn't
working out you should get rid of that
person should be as lean as possible
because smaller teams generally are more
efficient you know the larger teams and
having to having necessity is the mother
of invention is an incredibly powerful
force companies i have seen that raised
too much money end up being a little bit
sloppy they end up being a little bit
slower they end up delaying
profitability and and I know it doesn't
necessarily make logical sense because
people say well I'll just raise the
money and I'll leave it here and I won't
touch it and we'll still be really lean
and mean my experience is it just
doesn't happen that way it's just not
human nature I would hire after growth
you know it used to be like in the
bubble people would say well you got
higher in anticipation of growth that
didn't work so well you know my
experience is that if if you grow and
you're always just a little bit lean in
terms of not having enough people to
kind of take advantage of the
opportunity that's that's a pretty
healthy place to be it's a little bit
like having a lab you want to be just a
little bit on the lean side the fourth
is
maximize the pie not just your slice you
know at the end of the day if you start
a company any of you can own a hundred
percent of it but it probably won't be
that big I mean what you want to do is
you want to you want to try to figure a
way to make the pie as big as possible
so that the slices are really valuable
and then and then we talked about
choosing your investor as a true
business partner so I'll talk a little
bit for a minute about common
misconceptions the first is that the
customers are always right that's kind
of true but not always you know my
experience is that customers don't have
any vision they only have about a six to
12 12 months you know horizon and lots
of times when you're talking about
something that's never been done they
can't really conceptualize what it is
until they see it they're very few
people one of the reasons entrepreneurs
are so great and they're so cool and
there's so much fun to hang out with is
because they're able to see much farther
out and they see order what other people
see chaos most other people and that
means almost every customers they only
see you know six months or 12 months
ahead they don't see kind of the bigger
vision and so lots of times people make
the mistake of kind of listening to
customers so it doesn't mean you
shouldn't solicit did the input of
customers you should but you should also
recognize a customer's own always right
second is a higher experience over
talent I I see people that that will say
well we should hire this person because
you know that person's done that job
before and I would much rather hire an
up-and-coming a than a proven be right
and and lots of times people will go for
proven B's because they had they've had
the checkbox you know on the resume and
obviously you'd rather have a proven a
everybody would rather have a proven a
but if it were up to me I always bet on
young talent I always hire unproven A's
in favor of proven bees I hear this a
lot you know VCS will sell a company
from under me that that's just really
I've never had that happen in almost
every occasion where we have ended up
selling the company I find myself
constantly in the position of
encouraging the team to kind of go for
it and and let's see what we can make it
make at it and I would say that the when
their first-time entrepreneurs and they
get a
meaningful amount of money and the
ability to kind of take something off
the table um they almost all always take
it and they'll always say to me in the
conversate and the conversation would go
something like hey listen don't get that
many swings in the major league you know
your at-bat you're in the majors let's
take a shot and see how big we can make
it and if it doesn't work out then we
can always you know go back and they'll
stand they'll say well I understand but
you have a portfolio of companies and
you've done it before this is my only
bet this is my first bet and this is
like you know landscape changing and
life-changing for me and I think I owe
it to myself my family and all the
employees do that and I usually say
listen I support you a hundred percent
I'm just telling you what my position is
because at the end of the day if if you
mr. are mr or ms entrepreneur want to
sell the company i'm not going to stand
in your way i'm going to force them to
work when hey when they don't want to do
it i mean that that doesn't really make
any sense but that that's a a common
fallacy the fourth is i hear this a lot
from y combinator classes you know vc's
want to kick out the founders the first
chance they get that doesn't really make
sense either i mean when i'm investing
in a company where there are three
people why would i want to give them the
money to build a company and then
proceed to want to kick them out I mean
it doesn't it doesn't make any logical
sense you know my objective is for them
to succeed and if they succeed then I
really succeed now if they're not going
to succeed or they need help in order to
succeed then by all means i'm going to
go to them i try to convince them that
we should hire you know more people onto
the team to help them succeed but it's
see i hear this a little bit more than
I'm comfortable with that oh I hear VCS
want to just kick out the founders I
want to put in all these protective
provisions to prevent the founders from
getting kicked out I have no interest in
seeing any of them leave unless they're
not you know helping the cause and
causing the company to succeed and then
lastly good CEOs do what the board wants
I think I mentioned this earlier good
CEOs do what they think what they lead
the company and they make their own
independent decisions and I think when a
board makes decisions it's time for a
new CEO so that that's just not the case
so the final section and I'm going to
try to wrap this up really quickly is is
talk about what I'm looking for
what I'm looking for landscape changing
ideas i'm looking for ginormous markets
i'm looking for people who want to
change the world and i don't need a full
team when we invest I just need
everybody who's on the team to be really
good I just need a nucleus of excellence
and I'm looking for things that can be
great businesses and so I get asked a
lot well what you know what do you do
for due diligence you know there are
four things one I look at the value
proposition so how compelling is the
product or service and I'll do that by
doing some customer checks or by you
know anecdotal consumer checks a look at
markets I'll look at rough market size
estimations I'll do a lot of back of the
envelope I'll try to see what are
analogous type services or what are
analogous type products and how do I
figure out kind of how many customers
there are what their market adoption
rate is going to be and how much they'll
pay and I look for analogies all over
the place that lead me to give me some
level of comfort as to how big the
market sizes and it doesn't need to be
exact I think markets come in three
sizes small little and large I'm sorry
small medium and large and and and i'm
looking for large markets but i need to
know about how big the market is and if
it's big enough that that's really what
I'm looking for and I always look at
analogies in terms of evaluating people
i always look I'll oh I think I
mentioned this I look at what motivates
him or her if the person is very young
and they haven't had a lot of experience
I look for some patterns of excellence
and if there's a lot of patterns of
mediocrity well I tend to stay away from
that I always ask you know what do you
think are your strengths and weaknesses
because I want somebody who's really
self-aware and of course I'll call all a
bunch of other people that are on or off
their reference list to hear what other
people say and finally I want to predict
the business model you know I don't you
know not all businesses today have a
business model but I want to at least
have a thesis on what would could be and
we know what are the customer economics
and who else has done something like
this and I think I talked about that
before I'm going to skip that and go to
just talk about the quick rules are and
say you know my rules are you should
pick really big markets and like I said
it's either markets or people I'm on the
I'm about 5149 markets type person
market leaders get the majority rewards
you know never
eyes on people you know my observation
is that is higher B's B's hire sees and
once you get C's in the company like
cockroaches that cannot get them out you
should definitely do analysis do the
analysis at the end of the day you got
to go with your gut you can't do it
can't do analysis paralysis and I see
this all the time what you want to do is
enough work to know what kind of
decision you're making and then you're
going to make you going to make a gut
decision at the end of the day and
lastly be flexible there's more than one
path to success so I'm going to finish
with five pieces of advice for those
prospective entrepreneurs in the
audience one is to think huge it doesn't
make any sense to go after little
markets your time is too valuable oh the
second is once you decide to go you
should move go and move very quickly get
more help than you think you need you
can you can you know I know I said you
know higher after growth but but getting
help in over horse powering is typically
you want a lot of expertise you know in
a startup company because it's hard
don't focus on dilution focus on outcome
I think I've talked about that and
lastly learn from others who come before
you so with that I'm I apologize for
having gone through this also rapid fire
I'm happy to take any questions in the
remaining seven minutes
yeah thanks Jeff great tall and very
insightful what's your preferred source
of deal flow we've got a project think
effects how should we hastily um you
know I mean the best way the best entree
into any venture capitalist is is
through through referral you know
ideally and if there isn't then you just
you know just feel free to email any
anybody in the firm and everything will
get looked at right you know obviously
the way I mean the valley is a pretty
small place and you know all of us take
source of referral as a very more
seriously you know the better the source
of referral the more the more seriously
something somebody will take take it but
we look at everything yeah it's actually
it's inspirational talk english is
boring the ocean yes was wondering in
terms of market segments what do you
think is going to be the largest ocean
going forward you find you okay so the
question is what's the largest boiling
the ocean what's the largest segment of
the ocean that that's attractive and and
I I kind of there was a slide in here I
was going to talk a little bit about
what our core investment themes are but
you know generally generically speaking
you know platforms is a really
interesting place to be both new
platforms you know every time remember
mum says there's no more platforms right
and just like I remember when Google was
dominating search everybody said there's
nothing going to be you know it's going
to be in every internet search is going
to be dominated by a search bar and then
all of a sudden face up myspace comes
along and then Facebook comes along and
then Twitter comes along and so forth
and people say well nothing will ever
dominate the operating system world
because Windows has everything and then
all of a sudden Android and iOS come
along so I still think that there's
opportunity for new platforms is as you
know mobile you know the world goes
mobile and and and mobile devices really
become the the compute platform and
having so much power
those hands is really remarkable then
you also have applications on top of
existing platforms you know you can plug
into over 3 billion users by by
connecting to Facebook YouTube iOS
Android you know linkedin xbox I think
next generation entertainment is a space
that I'm spending a lot of time on
people are viewing entertainment all
sorts of different places on all sorts
of different pieces of glass and they
have right now finding content is really
difficult you have to enter credentials
in all over the place it's really hard
to you know contents more tied to a
device rather than to a person and you
have all this new content coming up I
may have talked about machinima we're
investing in that theme on
next-generation content networks you
know data is is huge I mean people were
spewing so much information out there
and everybody wants to be able to get
real-time analysis to be able crunch the
data and be able to have to be able to
look at it on their mobile phone or on
their tablet and then lastly enterprise
cloud mobile you know everything that's
happening in the consumer is moving to
the enterprise and I think that's going
to happen over the next ten years so
those are our four themes yeah I use for
example when the pivot how to pivot so
the question is do we have any advice on
how to when the pivot how to pivot and
when you let go of your baby and pivot
is little you know one of the most
popular words out there today and it
basically means something isn't working
but you have you know some resources or
you have a team and you want to apply
that to a new a new a new area you know
it's kind of hard to say because you
rarely ever get things right on the
first shot but what you're looking for
is some validation that what you're
doing you know has some traction and
then you're not pushing a rock up a hill
and so it's a really hard question to
answer you know kind of in the generic
but you kind of know when you feel it
you know if something starts working you
get a pretty good sense that it's
working but if it's been out there for a
while and you're not getting let's say
it's a consumer thing
not getting any real any real engagement
and things are just trailing off and
you've tried a whole bunch of different
hooks to try to get people to to use the
to use whatever you're trying to do then
that's probably a pretty good sign I'd
say you kind of know it when you see it
and you shouldn't you shouldn't give up
but you shouldn't bang your head against
the wall forever either yeah I just want
to know that what kind of skills that
you think is more important for another
foreigner because you said that the idea
is important as fair as it is the main
part and how can we come up what kind of
gives a bit of work to look for 30
college ideas and my next question is a
bit of specific I mean I've engineering
background and you said that the proof
is important not to attract investors so
we have to show them something into so
that they they trust us so technical
skills can be helpful but what other
skills okay so the question is what kind
of background is the best for starting a
company and what kind of skill sets so
so you know my observation is that the
best almost all great entrepreneurs I
think have a real product mentality you
know a byproduct I mean product or
service okay and and the best is the
best I find are people who have a
technical background but really
understand kind of can put their heads
and be the voice of the customer whether
consumer or it's it's a an enterprise
and so I always look for people who are
great product people you know ideally
you know so you look for engineers and
you look for engineers that aren't just
technically skilled but also like I know
a bunch of great engineers but they have
no product sense right and that's not
great if you are like that then marry
yourself with someone who's really good
product says I know a bunch of product
people who aren't technical but they
have a really good sense of what could
be done if I could just do it this way
they just don't know how to do if you're
that kind of person I'd marry yourself
with with a technical person but those
are the best people to start companies
they
and not to be the finance people that
tend not to be the manufacturing or
operations people tend not to be human
resources it tends to be some form of of
technical or marketing but the common
theme is product really heavy product
orientation and you wanted you want
somebody who's really the voice of the
customer the consumer
you